[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma a chi interessa scattare foto e
girare video con il cellulare è una
domanda che qualcuno si è fatto un po di
anni fa quando il primo cellulare ha
portato a bordo una videocamera
telecamera ma ci sono già le macchine
fotografiche le videocamere una follia
non serve a niente
adesso la situazione effettivamente è un
po diversa
guardate tutti ignorano in realtà non è
importante il re clinton ma è importante
farsi il self con il re clinton e dovete
sapere che questa frase questa domanda
che sembra adesso retorica se verrà
fatto un importantissimo guru della
tecnologia tra l'altro che anche di
queste parti e che adesso non arriva ma
adesso arriverà lo riconoscete questo
ero io che la prima volta che ho visto
un cellulare con la videocamera è detto
ma figurati sta roba qua ma chi vuoi che
la usi chivu per fortuna non era il
product manager di nokia o di samsung
altrimenti sarebbe stato veramente un
disastro ma ci sono stati altri
eccellenti fallimenti parlo un po del
mio settore che ho vissuto per tanti
anni
questo lo riconoscete tutti un giovane
steve jobs fenomeno osannato da tutto il
mondo ha rivoluzionato il mondo
però lui a un certo punto ha fatto next
quando fu estromesso da apple creò
questa nuova azienda non so in quanti di
voi lo ricordino comunque doveva essere
una sfida apple voi mi avete cacciato
adesso vi faccio vedere io
fu un fallimento totale doveva fare
computer super potenti così ne vendette
pochissimi spese un sacco di soldi e non
arrivò a nulla però fece anche pixar
voi dite è peak è stato un grande
successo
in realtà pixar se fosse stato per jobs
in realtà non sarebbe mai esistito
lui aveva investiti in pixar quando
pixar che è la casa che produce toy
story e tutti i film che ne sono seguiti
era una produttrice di hardware faceva
computer per case di animazione e lui
vestì per quello non ne venivano fuori
avevano quasi un unico cliente che era
disney e a un certo punto lassetter che
era di ceo di bitrel indici guarda
dobbiamo fare qualcosa qui stiamo
perdendo un sacco di soldi non si va da
nessuna parte
e lui sapeva testardo come era cioè no
no noi dobbiamo continuare a questa è la
nostra missione allora lancet air di
nascosto rispetto a jobs fece un corto
un piccolo video che loro usavano per
promuovere la potenza delle macchine lo
allargò lo fece un pochino più
articolato e lo portò a disney di
nascosto disney impazzì quando vide
questo video e gli attribuì la
produzione del primo toy story ed e
rinasce il grande successo di pixar
quindi vedete anche un guru assoluto
come è stato jobs ha avuto i suoi
fallimenti ma qui abbiamo un altro
signore uomo più ricco del mondo che a
un certo punto nella sua vita e dice nel
1993 the internet più note in triste dei
neet sentito noi internet nell'interesse
un gioco anzi se ricordate che alcuni di
voi quello un pochino con qualche anno
in più si voleva fare il suo microsoft
network la sua internet però bisogna
anche saper imparare dai fallimenti e
infatti lui che non era certo stupido
dopo poco di sequestro nel 96 quindi
solo tre anni dopo non dieci anni dopo
insistendo anche se avrebbe avuto le
risorse finanziarie per farlo
disse se tu non sei su internet non sei
nel business quindi l'umiltà a un certo
punto anche con una figuraccia se volete
mondiale di ammettere che quello era
stato un fallimento
quella sua affermazione
questo è il mio preferito questo è il
mio preferito adesso lui non è un
personaggio molto noto però forse lo
potete riconoscere dallo sfondo che a
questo è sì all night il fondatore di
nike nike in vi invito a leggere la sua
biografia è una storia imprenditoriale
straordinario io ho sempre pensato prima
che fosse che avesse modo di leggere
questo sua biografia che fosse una di
quelle operazioni molto marketing molto
americana belli europei hanno puma
adidas bene adesso noi facciamo il
nostro marchio ricerche di marketing è
invece una saga imprenditoriale
straordinaria che parte con un ragazzo
che parte per un viaggio in giro per il
mondo un sabbatico e arriva in giappone
ma non visse poi loro il resto vi dico
soltanto questo che a un certo punto lui
dice al freddo
la suola si staccava e si crepa va fino
a quando quelle nike e non si disintegra
rono altro fallimento la gomma era
troppo rigida troppo friabile si ruppe
subito sembravano coperte di una vernice
o lacca a buon mercato che non si era
asciugata il logo sul fianco quello che
tutti a verso idolatriamo quella specie
di ala che sa nemmeno lui all'inizio
leggerete così convinceva troppo era di
formato sedetti con la testa fra le mani
il gran finale è adesso era chicago
gravato dai debiti a capo di una
traballante azienda di scarpe a
immettere sul mercato una nuova marca di
fattura scadente con il logo storto
perché la prima partita aveva pure il
logo storto di night il risultato qual è
stato lo scorso anno conto economico del
2016 ricavi per 32 billion con un utile
netto di 3.7 miliardi da quel fallimento
quasi certo in cui a un certo punto si
era trovato film knight è riuscito a
ricavarne
tutto questo quindi il fallimento è una
parte integrante di quello che noi
possiamo fare soprattutto nella
creazione di un'azienda è impossibile
non fallire chi parte pensando di non
fallire mai è uno sciocco perché tu devi
provare fallire riprovare ancora abbiamo
sentito prima
edison quante volte ha provato e a un
certo punto
a quel punto arriverai al successo il 50
per cento delle startup fallisce nei
primi cinque anni
quindi quando si sa mettere il cuore in
pace che ha una probabilità su due di
chiudere e una su 700 diventa uno
unicorn unicorn negli stati uniti sono
quelle realtà che arrivano ad avere una
capitalizzazione un valore superiore al
billion dollar cioè ai mille miliardi
quindi vuol dire non soltanto facebook
google ma anche snap chat o cose del
genere
però una su 700 e qui naturalmente
arrivano le storie di successo tutti
pensano che in silicon valley basta
aprire una start up e diventare
milionario miliardari come in questo
caso non è assolutamente così
soltanto una su 700 diventa una di
quelle società che tutti noi conosciamo
noi abbiamo analizzato delle interviste
con la nostra tecnologia di interviste
fatte a imprenditori che avevano fallito
e abbiamo raccolto in due diciamo tag
cloud quelli che sono i concetti che
emergevano di più all'interno di queste
interviste sono diverse centinaia di
interviste e vedete guardate un po di
questi concetti che sono quelli negativi
sono chiaramente i problemi abbiamo
fatto degli errori mistake il fallimento
qualcuno adduce la sfortuna ma è già un
po più piccolo perché la sfortuna si
diciamo che può avere essere la
componente ma molto molto marginale
difficoltà critica queste sono i
concetti di natura negativa ma guarda te
qui noi abbiamo realizzato anche i
concetti di natura positiva cioè in un
fallimento che cosa ci può essere
ci può essere comunque un successo una
crescita gross leggete quelli che volete
guardate non sono opportunity cioè ecco
anche il fallimento è un'opportunità io
personalmente ho visto in silicon valley
due persone uno che era il finanziatore
di questa startup e l'altro era
l'imprenditore e la startup aveva chiuso
era fallita
tutti ci avevano provato tutti ci
avevano provato nel modo migliore
possibile
questi due si sono lasciati stringendosi
la mano dicendo good luck cioè andiamo
oltre e perché abbiamo fatto il
possibile e il fallimento è parte di
questo processo come dicono americani
sometimes i waines sometimes you learn
cioè il fallimento vero e non imparare
anche dal fallimento piccolo grande che
sia e soprattutto fallisce sicuramente
chi ha paura di fallire è un concetto
che io racconto spesso perché molte
volte non si parte nemmeno per la poli
fallire per la paura poi di essere
additati come quelli che hanno fallito
sicuramente se non si parte se si ha la
convinzione di farla la voglia di farlo
chiaramente è quello il punto di
partenza non aver paura di fallire
ad esempio noi quando siamo abbiamo
cominciato molti anni fa sull'onda della
prima ha intelligenza artificiale a
cavallo della fine degli anni 80 inizia
nei 90 volevamo fare sistemi esperti
infatti il nostro nome expert system
tradisce queste nostre origini
ma in una terra che sappiamo bene
tortellini auto lo zampone il lambrusco
ho messo anche una cartolina proprio
vintage di quei tempi
e noi cominciamo da giovani ragazze
appena laureati a fare sistemi esperti
dopo probabilmente sei otto mesi avevamo
capito che saremmo morti di fame no
forse morti fa qualcuno a casa che c'era
un pezzo di pane c'era ma sicuramente
non saremmo andati molto lontano
quindi è stato un fallimento quasi
immediato e abbiamo dovuto capire come
potevamo convogliare questa nostra
voglia di fare intelligenze ufficiale in
un contesto che in quel momento era
impossibile tenete conto che lo
smartphone che voi avete in tasca adesso
è forse dieci volte più potente del più
potente computer di quei tempi e quindi
era tecnicamente impossibile anche se
noi avevamo studiato io sotto
l'ombrellone mi leggevo i libri
intelligenza artificiale cioè quei mia
moglie che può testimoniarlo in platea
mi pediatrico a leggere la gazzetta
dello sport sotto l'ombrellone io
leggevo i liberi intelligenza
artificiale però non era possibile ma
noi ci siamo arrivati adesso lungo
percorso che non vi sto a raccontare ma
adesso noi facciamo intelligenza
artificiale anzi lo facciamo già da
molti anni ma all'inizio quei tempi non
era possibile quindi che cosa vuol dire
vuol dire che tu devi avere sempre un
approccio umile con le cose che fai
perché è difficile che tutto vada come
tu avevi pensato però devi avere lo
stesso tempo il coraggio il coraggio di
affrontare le sfide il coraggio di
affrontare anche nuove si tratti di
coraggio di affrontare i fallimenti una
grandissima determinazione lo avete già
sentito più di una volta negli
interventi precedenti
se vuoi fare l'imprenditore devi essere
veramente molto determinato ma questo
poi ti serve anche in altri contesti non
soltanto nel contesto del business e
avere l'intelligenza di mettere insieme
tutto questo
lasciatemi dire un'ultima cosa la
fortuna a cui facevo riferimento prima
deriva anche dal fatto di dove nasce
perché quello non lo puoi scegliere e io
credo di avere la fortuna di essere nato
in un territorio che mi ha dato tanti
grandi esempi che mi ha ispirato fin da
piccolo e esempi famosi ma anche esempi
molto meno famosi e grazie a questo mi
ha trasmesso questa mia voglia di fare
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]